[Music]
a heart for his wife julia
the only goodbye alexayna valni could
manage before heading to prison
earlier he told the court the charges
against him were fabricated
a way of intimidating his supporters
all of these officers and this cage it's
not a show of strength
it shows their weakness they are weak
and they cannot jail thousands or even
millions of people
outside the cavalry arrived early
lines of riot police stood in front of
the court
not to keep navalny in but to keep his
supporters out
as the day progressed police detained
hundreds of navalny supporters
who'd come to show their solidarity
age was no barrier this woman stood her
ground in defiance
as night fell on moscow the protests
grew
but so did the presence of police in
riot gear
and the arrests
detention is a price these protesters
are willing to pay
to speak their mind
i don't want my children to grow up in
the same conditions i did
alex say is trying to do something at
least
navalny has just been wrongly convicted
the country will never be free if the
authorities and the courts behave like
this
it looks like they will soon start
beating us with their batons again
but we came out so that our children
won't be beaten with batons in the
future
soon enough the police proved him right
their batons directed indiscriminately
at anyone in the crowd
navalny supporters are taking risks in
the hope the next generation won't have
to
let's give more now we are joined by
andreas nick a member of the german
bundestag and the governing
conservatives he heads germany's
delegation
to the parliamentary assembly of the
council of europe welcome to the program
and thank you so much for joining us
the german government has condemned the
jail sentence for alexi navalny
is that enough
it is an important first step i think we
are very
concerned but also very impressed by the
courageous way that russian civil
society
protests against this development it
shows how much
pressure how much tension is there in
russia it is a domestic issue in the in
the first place
but it is an issue that has an important
impact on all international obligations
that russia has entered to whether it's
in the council of europe in the osce or
in other structures
and and that is why it is an important
element of international
obligations and and contractual
obligations and that's what we are
pursuing the verdict on which mr navalny
was
detained again was already
rendered obsolete by the european court
of human rights a couple of years ago
and that is something that the council
of europe in all its
institutional directions will have to
deal with going
in the next few weeks and it is uh
the obvious point of uh addressing this
because
russia is violating international
obligations that
the russian federation has entered okay
so
you say that the condemnations are an
important first step what is the second
step because we know that the eu for
example has already imposed targeted
sanctions because of
the poisoning of alexi navalny so what
should come
next and you know if the second step is
sanctions in your opinion can they
really make a difference
i think it is an important next step to
send a double message to russia both in
terms of the government
as in terms of the society that we are
strictly looking at the adherence to
constitutional obligations to
international obligations when it comes
to the freedom of speech to the
freedom of assembly to the rule of law
to
compliance with the judgments of the
european court of human rights
to which russia is a contractual party
but that at the same we are considering
all options
to increasing the pressure
and make clear also to the russian
leadership that there is
a price to be paid that there is a cost
to this behavior
and this is going to unfold over the
next couple of weeks should one of those
costs be
gas exports because earlier this week
france's european affairs minister
renewed pressure on germany to stop the
nordstrom 2 gas pipeline project
um it of course is scheduled to bring
russian gas to germany
um they're they're they're uh saying
that this should be a response the
cancelling of the project should be a
response to the navalny case
does germany need to seriously consider
doing more
in order to pull this project
i think we should narrow this discussion
to the completion
of the construction of nordstrom 2 i
think if we are considering the whole
set of options we should be talking
about asset freezes we should be talking
about travel bans
and we could have a very serious and
honest debate about
the energy relationships of everyone
with russia in this context
but i think for this debate to be honest
and meaningful i think everything has to
be on the table it is not about
bilateralizing this into a german
russian issue then we need to talk about
a 30 billion dollar of u.s oil
purchases of crude oil from russia we
need we would also need to talk about
gas export gas imports in central
eastern europe
i think to bilateralize it and to just
talk about one specific issue i think
is not uh meaningful it's just abusing
the nevada case for
certain political and commercial
interests there are some in your party
and i'd just like to bring in a quote
right now um from norbert rutkin for
example who's
who's as you know has been quite vocal
on this issue he's he said that
going ahead with the north stream two
project would and i'm quoting here
be the ultimate confirmation for
vladimir putin that he is pursuing
exactly the right policy
because the west is doing nothing at
least in the areas
that interest him i mean what message
does it send to putin
that if this project does indeed go
ahead that he can silence his critics
and
there will be no real consequences no
that's not what i said i think
i think there's always been a
significant scepticism towards this
project
in my own party the different views from
the economic and from the foreign policy
side
uh but given and i was never arguing
for this project at the outset but we
have to see where we are just briefly
before completion of a construction
for which all permits are in place this
would probably trigger billions of
dollars in
damage payments i'm not sure we should
be wanting that
to trigger but if we are if we are
talking about putting a freeze of
oil and gas purchases from russia
altogether in the west we will probably
have a serious conversation on that
but we should not uh allow that to be
just being bilateralized and i think if
you go back to
a very smart analysis that secretary of
state lincoln has
written more than 30 years ago
about a former dispute on
gas imports from siberia i think we
could have a
good basis with the new yes
administration to come to common ground
in addressing that but i think we should
not only talk about this commercial
aspect we should make absolutely clear
russia is not in compliance with its
obligations on the issue international
law under
its membership in the council of europe
and the osce and we need to see that we
exert maximum pressure and use all the
instruments available in these
institutions
to improve the situation of those in
russia mr navalny and the process has
detained
and those protesting in the streets we
thank you so much for joining us this
morning um
to to to share that view andreas nick
a member of the german bundestag and the
governing conservatives also head of
germany's delegation to the
parliamentary assembly of the council of
europe we appreciate it
thank you
you